so today we're going to cancel the la
times for this article from noah
biermann titled
black female and high profile kamela
harris is a top target in online fever
swamps
the article's meant to perpetuate the
myth that left-wing women especially
left-wing
non-white women are special victims of
abuse and harassment online of course
there's no doubt that they are targeted
for abuse and harassment online
everyone is the more high profile you
are the more of a target you become
nobody doubts this but the claim is that
women of color to use the momentarily
preferred pc moniker
are more often victims of this kind of
treatment than anyone else
the reasons that the media is so
determined to push this narrative i
think are pretty obvious for
one thing if if left-wing minority women
are most often victimized by online
harassment
that would mean that white right-wing
males presumably are most often the ones
committing online harassment
of course in reality women harass each
other way more often
than men harass women but we're talking
about the media narrative here and what
they want us to believe
the media is eager for any opportunity
to cast their most despised group in the
villain role so that's one thing
for another thing this is all part of
the ongoing effort by the media and the
democrat party to push
social media to and the social media
platforms to ramp up their censorship
and that's made clear at the very start
in the article it says quote
soon after joe biden announced last year
that he would pick a woman as his
running mate
democratic congresswoman jackie speier
began warning facebook executives
female politicians received the most
vile online attacks
and the company's filters were falling
failing to stop them
spyer said we showed them 20 examples
that were disgusting
and they were still up she was talking
about a meeting
with chief operating officer sheryl
sandberg at facebook facebook's response
gave her a little comfort
keep sending us these horrific examples
she said executives told her
and we'll take them down spire's
concerns that the first female vice
president would
would attract outsized assaults and
venomous lies from social media's
ugliest players
have now been validated research shows
that camilla harris may be the most
targeted american politician on the
internet
one who checks every box for the haters
of the fever swamps she's a woman she's
a person of color
and she holds power okay now already we
know that this
cannot be true the idea that camilla
harris
attracts more venom than donald trump is
absurd on its face
there there cannot possibly be a more
targeted american politician on the
internet than donald trump
the only way they could justify this
claim is if they hinge it on the
technicality that donald trump is out of
office at the moment so he's
he isn't technically a politician but
even putting trump aside is camilla
harris more targeted than say
ted cruz and what do we mean by targeted
what counts as abuse and harassment what
is meant by
venomous lies well let's keep reading
it says quote abuse directed at women is
highly personalized
often attacking them based on their
appearance and denigrating their
intelligence
said cecile goran a researcher in london
at the institute for strategic dialogue
a think tank that sinks to that seeks to
counter extremism disinformation and
polarization
she said it's also uh more likely to
imply that they should quit politics and
that they don't belong in the public
space
oh abuse directed at women is highly
personalized you say
yes as opposed to abuse directed at men
which we all know is not personal at all
it wasn't personal when trump was called
fat and ugly approximately 7 million
times a day on the internet
7 million by my account anyway and my
accounting method isn't any less
scientific than whatever method they're
using
there are currently hundreds of memes
comparing mitch mcconnell to a turtle
that's an attack based on appearance
it's also kind of true but that's beside
the point
and the claim that women are uniquely
insulted based on their intelligence
is well the kind of claim that only a
person of low intelligence could believe
woman or man more from the article says
goran led a recent study that did not
include harris but showed that american
female politicians were two to three
times more likely to receive abusive
twitter comments than male counterparts
such findings elevate widespread
concerns that women still significantly
underrepresented in political and
corporate offices
will avoid or give up leadership jobs
that leave them vulnerable to online
abuse
it certainly discourages women from
getting engaged in politics speyer said
given worries about family and personal
safety
okay a study
well here we go it should be clear to
you now that uh it should be clear to
you by now that whenever a
study is referenced in a mainstream
media article the person making the
reference is counting on you
not actually reading the study that's
the great thing about studies
many people seem to think that that a
point can be proven simply by saying the
word study
the the word study is enough this is
what passes for an argument nowadays oh
yeah you don't believe me well a study
says i'm right
oh a study well if the study says it
then never mind
i happen to be one of those annoying
people who actually wants to read the
study
see when you tell me about a study i'm
going to say i want to see it show me
the study
i'm going to read it myself and in
reading studies i have found and i have
no studies to prove this i admit
but i found that most studies are to put
this scientifically bullcrap
keep in mind that you can call anything
a study there's no required standard
methodology for a study
that's why reading the study itself is
so important so let me let me read a bit
of this study to you
the title of the study is public figures
public rage
candidate abuse candidate abuse on
social media that's the title
skipping ahead to page 12 it says
we analyzed the language most often used
to target candidates over the 11 day
period of study and extracted a list of
surprising keywords and phrases for each
individual in a three-step process
one we obtained 20 keywords by
contrasting the data from tweets to a
sample of standard english wikipedia
data
helping identify uncommon vocabulary two
we extracted 20 keywords by contrasting
the individual of interest twitter data
with that of other candidates to
identify language
specifically targeting that person three
we filtered these 40 keywords out
through a blacklist likely to generate
background noise
for this research we blacklisted the
terms trump covid the individual's name
and common aliases political party names
and common state names
we ordered keywords and phrases by their
degree of unexpectedness
and selected the top 20. now
what what does any of that mean degree
of unexpectedness
how the hell do you measure that i mean
doesn't this whole process sound
extremely arbitrary and subjective
they're also only taking into account
public comments made to these figures
in my experience by far the worst abuse
comes through email and private message
any study of online abuse that doesn't
factor private messages
is pretty worthless it would seem it's
like measuring the amount of bullying in
school but not counting gym class or the
cafeteria
those are like the bullying factories
you can't you can't take that out of it
at any rate on the next page is a table
listing keywords and phrases used to
target candidates
here are some of the keywords and
phrases for ilhan omar
shameful defund the police
and somalia wow how abusive
now for nancy pelosi hypocrites
unverified
antifa yes apparently to call out a
woman's hypocrisy
or to say that her claims are unverified
is abusive now
the study then gives real world examples
of abusive comments made to nancy pelosi
so here's one this is a
this is an actual abusive comment that
the study shows and this shows us what
they consider to be abusive
so somebody some abusive scoundrel said
to nancy pelosi
she's not doing a very good job better
get on that nan
here's one to ilhan omar she's an
anti-american she's as
anti-american and anti-constitutional as
they come this is a republican
or a public not a democracy if she
doesn't understand that she'll never
understand the constitution or the bill
of rights
that's the abuse but no this is not
abuse this is not harassment this is
called criticism
she's not doing a good job is a very
civilized
very understated very polite way of
criticizing a politician who in fact is
not doing a good job the comment about
ilhan omar is also a criticism
and also well deserved but this is what
the study which spawned the la times
article categorizes as
vile anti-woman misogynistic abuse
do you want to know what an actual
abusive comment sounds like
i'll give you one here it is i know what
city you're in
white you think you can keep talking
behind your phone in tweets
i'll smoke you stupid ass take care of
your ugly white daughter
that was a message sent to me recently
threatening to hunt me down and murder
me along with my seven-year-old daughter
that checks all the boxes doesn't it
racist insulting
explicitly threatening if you want a
more recent example here's one that came
to my inbox
just this morning i went online first
thing as i always do
had my cup of coffee and uh you know
starting the day it had the pleasure of
reading this
f you i hope you die like the rest of
your pathetic ilk you support
now pretty tame compared to a lot of the
stuff i get but even so wishing death on
me
i've received literally thousands of
messages emails and comments like this
thousands threatening death wishing
death
threatening harm against my children
wishing harm against my children
comments merely mocking my appearance
are so utterly banal at this point that
i don't even notice them
if i do notice them i'm tempted to send
a message back
thanking the person because at least
they didn't promise to burn down my
house with my family trapped inside
compared to that kind of feedback
calling me ugly seems downright polite
now do i receive more than my fair share
of this kind of vitriol
i don't know probably not i have no way
of knowing
what i do know is that being a white
male with a platform on the internet
does not in
any way protect you from quote abuse
i can tell you that from experience
trust me now the unfortunate thing is
that the insistence on focusing
on the gender and racial components of
this issue the effort to fit online
harassment and abuse into the standard
mainstream
victimhood narrative prevents us from
having what could otherwise be
a valuable and necessary conversation no
women are not specially targeted black
people are not specially targeted
but they are targeted everybody is
and though many of the examples provided
in the study are pretty trite
i have no doubt that you know the people
that are mentioning this study
receive plenty of these sort of i hope
you die go kill yourself type comments
just as i do
we're used to people saying that kind of
stuff on the internet
i'm used to people telling me that they
hope my family dies painfully
because they disagree with my political
opinions i'm used to it we're used to it
but we shouldn't be i mean it does say
something quite disturbing about
humanity
that this is how we treat each other
when we have the cloak of anonymity to
protect us
that's a conversation i would really
like to have that's a conversation we
should be having
because there are a lot of people who
want to dismiss all of this and say oh
it's just the internet it doesn't count
no it's not just the internet these are
people
the person who threatened to kill my
seven-year-old daughter because he
doesn't he doesn't agree with my
opinions
that's an actual person now he's not
actually going to do it
i'm not going to assume he's not going
to do it i did we did contact the police
and we reported it
because you make a threat against my
family that's what's going to happen
every time
but i'm not i don't actually think he's
going to do it
thousands of messages of this sort
nobody they don't really do it but
but these are these are people though
behind these messages
actual people talking to other actual
people
the fact that they'll only speak this
way on the internet
you know that that doesn't make it
better that only makes it worse
because what it tells you that is that
on top of being vile scumbags these are
also
cowards you know you tell someone to
kill themselves
because you disagree with their opinion
you would never say that to their face
but that's because you're a coward
the fact that you would say it at all
still makes you a vile disgusting
dirtbag and what we've discovered from
the internet which is maybe no big
surprise
there are a lot a lot of
cowardly vile disgusting dirt bags out
there they're not they're not
unique to one side or the other
but they're a lot of them that is a
conversation i would like to have we
should be having that conversation
not to push for censorship or anything
like that but just to say what the hell
is going on
with humanity right now but we can't
have it
because it always has to go down to race
and gender and the standard victim of
narratives
and that's why the la times is cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content